thank you very much good morning
after the distressing images we've seen
i'd like to address the question what
expert institutions like the engineers
museum
in berlin can actually do what measures
they can take
to
address the issue of protecting the
cultural heritage of iraq and syria at
home and more specifically what we are
doing at the moment
i would like to touch briefly upon four
points actually integrated object care
and presentation
fighting the illicit traffic in cultural
property on a national level bilateral
capacity building programs and finally
finally raising awareness for cultural
property per dec protection
let me start by briefly introducing the
engineering museum located in the
pergamon museum on berlin's museum
island
the engineers museum houses a collection
of about 500 000 objects from ancient
mesopotamian
society so it's a collection of
reference for these ancient mesopotamian
societies we have signature collections
from iraq and syria namely asur babylon
uruk
telhalaf kabira to name only a few
and it's important to point out that 95
percent of these collections come from
regular archaeological excavations
mostly at the beginning of the 20th
century
and they were transferred to berlin on
the basis of bilateral division
agreements with the respective source
countries
we have been a leading research
institution with a focus on
object-oriented research and in our
mission statement we say that we
consider ourselves a public repository
for the archaeological heritage of iraq
and syria
of course dealing with this heritage and
protecting it starts in our storage
facilities so what we're doing of course
is something that i would like to call
the integrated object care and
presentation when i say integrated i
mean that these objects are not only
considered by us as archaeological
objects or pieces of art but also as
cultural heritage of iraq and syria and
this integrated object care and
presentation includes state-of-the-art
storage
preventive conservation digital
documentation especially in the area of
3d digitization basic research very
important provenance research on the
history of the individual collections
and a multi-perspective
presentation
the second area of activity i would like
to comment upon is fighting the illicit
traffic we've just inaugurated a large
national research project focusing on
the illicit traffic with archaeological
objects in germany the project is called
illicid and in london i should probably
point out that this is not a mistake not
a spelling mistake but an acronym for a
german title
we're undertaking an explorative study
with special attention to archaeological
objects from iraq and syria which means
we're
looking into object types
turnovers networks operation modes etc
very important is that this is a
transdisciplinary research design which
also relies on non-academic partners
especially law enforcement and customs
authorities
our associated partners include the
federal foreign office the federal
commissioner for culture and media the
german commission for unesco and of
course i come with it international
observatory of illicit trafficking the
project is financed by the federal
ministry for education and research
generously with 1.2
million
third
area of activity that's important for us
is what we call bilateral capacity
building programs together with our
partners from iraq we're about to
initiate
an iraqi german expert dialogue on
iraq's cultural heritage at
archaeological sites and museums icasm
is supposed to be a bilateral expert
panel for the planning and coordination
of a large-scale capacity building
cooperation program between iraq and
germany so we're talking about an expert
panel that is setting out methodological
and operational guidelines defining
infrastructural political legal
scientific and operational requirements
for a sustainable exchange and
development of knowledge in iraq that is
important the project was initiated by
the permanent delegate of iraq to unesco
and the ancient near east museum the
partners here include the german
commission for unesco and the orient
department of the german archaeological
institute as well as i can financial
support comes from the federal foreign
office
and my final and last point as a public
institution we know that we have to
raise awareness for the cultural
property protection agenda as a whole
and we're doing that on a lot of
different fields and one example of
course
is
our public support for the ongoing
revision of the german cultural property
protection law from 2007 most of you
will know that the new law is aiming at
better import controls more effective
return mechanisms and strict due
diligence principles related to the eu
directive 60 2014
the new law also envisions export
documentation by the respective source
countries for all archaeological objects
to be imported to germany this is very
important if it actually happens it will
change things completely and the german
government has
pleaded or actually
recommended that the
eu council also deal with this problem
and implements corresponding measures on
the eu level because it is clear that as
long as there is illicit trafficking
with archaeological objects from iraq
and syria it will not be able to protect
this cultural heritage effectively in
the future thank you very much